anncr TV host michelle malkin former
deputy assistant to the president Fox
News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka I want to be very clear
Michelle nobody has a monopoly there are
horrible Republicans out there horrible
people in general that's not what I'm
describing here I am describing
systematically because of politics the
Clintons were protected by the media and
they went out and just abused these
women again and again and smeared them
to death even up to and including
through the election last year that's
right Sean and this is not ancient
history you're going to have all of
these liberal weed lers out there asking
oh why is Sean Hannity and Michelle
Malkin and and Sebastian gorica talking
about Bill Clinton it's because so much
of the mess that we're in now is a
result and legacy of the clinton victim
smear machine these two are the
godparents Hillary and Bill Clinton the
godparents of victim shaming smear
tactics and now we've got this case
where you've got all of these liberal
media journalists who are tying
themselves in yoga knots to try and
reconcile their own roles and their own
culpability in enabling the Clinton
smears against all of his accusers and
victims with the left-wing feminist
ideology of believing all women and now
what we know of course is it's not
revelation it's merely confirmation
Shawn that the idea that we should
believe all women has an exception
really the rules for radicals 2017 has
always been that you should believe all
women except when they are accusing
liberal democratic men and liberal
Hollywood weirdos there's a second
corollary to that unwritten rule that is
now being exploded and exposed for the
far set it is and that second corollary
is this Shawn and dr. Gorka it's this
that all women must be respected unless
of course they are female Republicans
conservatives pro-lifers stay-at-home
moms and gun owners I have
lived this for the past 25 years in
public life along with all of the women
who have been smeared by leftists in the
media and in the Democrat Party
we're always treated as less than women
as less than human and we have when we
have called out the misogyny and the
hypocrisy and the double standards of
the left we get attacked even more the
hypocrisy and double standards are
thicker than Thanksgiving gravy all
right dr. Gork oh wow I don't know how I
followed that Michelle is absolutely
right but let me expand the optic here
there's there's the issue of the
absolute double standards on the left so
now 30 years later they find a morality
so it's okay if Al Franken admits to it
then it just disappears as an issue you
look at Bob Menendez senator Menendez
we're not gonna cover that story but we
don't have the proof on judge Moore and
he's the problem so number one Shawn
it's the unbelievable level of double
standards but the second thing is beyond
that it's what cheryl atkinson has
written about in her book smear it's the
persistent smear tactics just making
stuff up because it's politically
expedient to your friends how is it that
you have all these individuals who are
supposed to be journalists but they
literally manufacture stories out of
nothing to attack the president
sometimes it's trivial you remember
recently the the fish feeding event in
japan right where they they crop out
that the president is actually doing
exactly what his host did before why cuz
it's expedient to make the president
look bad or it gets far more serious CNN
is going to say that James Comey is
going to counter everything the
president said about the FBI
investigating him or not it goes on and
on and on because it's all about
politics it's never about the truth
Shawn it's never just about journalism
all right
dr. korkor we're gonna keep Michelle so
I want to get you one more quick
question here what happens how do you
ascertain Charlie roses is admitting it
Franken we have the picture some cases
you have evidence
Clinton's over time will
revealed that these things that happen
what are you doing that is he-said
she-said how do how do people ascertain
the difference in an environment where
allegations are flying some people deny
them say it didn't happen it's all about
two things the credibility of the source
is the individual credible and can it be
corroborated the big problem we have
today short is we don't have
investigative journalists anymore the
people like sericata
they are so rare today they give a 21
year old kid a computer and access to
Google and they call him a journalist
that's how Politico works that's how
half Poe works you can get to the bottom
of this but you've got to wear out shoe
leather you've got to talk people to
talk you've got to corroborate the
stories and that just isn't done anymore
it's just accusations thrown out there
for political damage dr. korkor thank
you for being with us Michelle Wilkins